o lado diz pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que faz night é
trash highlands
temos pessoal e steel vai ser muito fofo
quem é assustador especificamente um
jogo foi meio do site friends mas com as
personagens de disney ou seja vai ser
mesmo de burrada cueca pessoal eu pelo
menos acho porque eu nunca achei piada
as personagens da disney
eu tenho assim aquela teoria que todas
as personagens de disney tem o seu lado
maligno por trás delas
então isso vai ser muito assustador
mesmo como vocês podem ver nós já temos
aqui um mickey à frente com um discurso
muito bizarras e tem que alguém falar
por trás mas vamos lá então começar o
jogo só fala sério tô super ansioso por
jogar isto porque aumentar o volume iii
bora lá ok noite um outro facto era um
homem muito bom nunca mas ok ok como é
que o jogo isto é que só vamos avião só
ligar pra mim e deu bem mas ninguém
ficou ontem esquema rock nacional
o menino que fraca 'basta' sobre douglas
chuta mal eu também falo quando a pérola
negra
michael jackson unidade nacional
ainda lá sem bucha de new york e jogar
só o galo espera envolver tudo soube que
acabada a lei da fila ao embalo tá bom
pode escalar agora pro pessoal
basicamente explicou
mika e este zé manel destaque da etapa
pedonal não sabem se guiné é basicamente
ele é segurança gilson de consegue ouvir
e quando eu é por ser a nossa frente nós
temos que desligar as câmeras eu acho
que foi isso eu não sei se bem mas
basicamente é isso nós temos que
desligar as câmeras não eu apanhei anos
ok até agora nada pessoal é uma da manhã
é e supostamente ter uma idéia a moça já
devem ser tipo duas noites a uma noite
mexe eu quero chegar ao fim deste ano
também e eu ainda vou chegar à noite gol
de fred do fluminense fred pessoal não
se preocupem quando eu consegui passar a
noite oposta o vídeo é e até agora ainda
não condicionada ao que o patronal está
aqui comigo está tranqüilo porque o
planeta meu sonho é que o pt também tem
um planeta que esperar o quarteto mickey
e pato donald e mais quem é o que é que
falta aqui espera espera lá eu vou ver
se consigo encontrar mais pessoas eu
consigo enxergar as câmeras também ok
tudo tranquilo wall street espera espera
espera espera espera do tranquilo cras
estava ali alguém atrás da caixa para
qualquer a câmera era essa tal de alguém
que só vocês vêem os pés de alguém eu
não sei se é mas talvez alguém atrás da
caixa
roque outra que o igp-m calma calma os
países chute off e câmeras é é isso que
eu tenho que fazer isto vamos salvar
assim como como eu desliguei as câmeras
meu
ok do primeiro o primeiro eu não gosto
do mickey meu lá ninguém ninguém
sua lenda agora com o santos o japão foi
um susto meu ok eu preciso fazer isso
mais cedo supostamente preciso desativar
as camas mais rápido eu acho que isso
obrigado a ouvir outra vez
opa o miguel vanthoor sua cápsula fique
que espera que o homem é capaz de falar
e me que está p
o cej e vem até nós né calma calma eu
preciso mandar abaixo da câmara isso ok
ok é eu eu acho que é isso ainda não sei
o que estou a fazer um mix postumamente
está lá em cima agora o atleta está aqui
ok eu não consegui ver o jornal porque
eu também estava lá e com mickey
portanto é só me resta esperar que o
metacritic né
anda lá daquela câmara baixo os outros
todos estão estão ainda o neném caiu
patetas que se seguem não é tipo patente
desse tipo a raposa josé rabusa que
desfaz na e3 já eu antes
está tudo tranqüilo atrás da caixa meu
filho ligou funk tranquilo
ok esta campanha está apagada aqui está
tudo tranquilo
a câmera sem meu carro me que se eu dou
i ii vi ninguém está mais jovem o maior
devolveu o susto é justo aqui ninguém
aqui está o pateta que está tudo
tranqüilo aqui é muito assustador o que
eu tava deitado eu acho que não percebeu
a pouco eu não sei se houve ou não
está tudo tranqüilo 12 da manhã pessoal
eu acho que isso também é até às seis
supostamente se for como o fight night
at freddy's é volta aqui pro teu amigo
pato o botafogo não ficou com os olhos
preto espero eu vou pagar esta câmera
foi isto que a câmera calma calma garoto
tranqüilo com a minha câmera pelo sim
pelo não a econômica em meu dever aqui
perto
é que lá em cima para voltar a crescer
também
só pra garantir que estiveram em um
mickey eu volto lá para cima
são três da manhã pessoal estamos
limitados à noite
basicamente três já elano significa a a
ilha do tesouro então nós mesmo estando
há 505 relate porque temos água à nossa
volta porque estamos numa ilha estamos
completamente richard atestado do mapito
pessoal vejam aqui o mapa está aqui o
mapa da ilha
nós temos completa em tramados meu ok
mickey na irlanda nikkei perdeu por
completo já muito tempo vai aparecer à
frente né vai aparecer à frente ao que o
jornal está aqui sozinho eu vou pegar a
câmera eye mil já estão nomes como as
duas coisas da câmera calma meu mickey
desapareceu já muito tempo
só por cima muito tempo vai aparecer à
frente a frente o aluno não consegue ver
bem está muito escuro cai aqui hoje
amanhã em natal e está pagando o pato
está aqui também nada do mickey já muito
tempo quatro da manhã avança avança ou
avança ok tá que tá aqui vou eu vou
pegar a câmera ok só peguei a câmera
porque eu estava olhando pra ela eu não
me pode ver eu viajar e cego nem eu não
poder ouvir é isso
calma lá pergunta indagou só fazem bem
era muito mau se uma distância enquanto
tapir agostinho da porcaria pessoal
porque ainda assim que a minha falta nos
uma hora uma foca em hora
ok eu fico lá em cima eu acho que ela
ainda está apagada por isso é tranqüilo
é completamente cego eu não vai seguir
anda lá não quero câmera uma quebra isso
pronto até tentar voltar rápido uma
câmera duas toda meu lá ok falta de uma
hora pessoal sim também é 5 foi que
horas da manhã e um mickey está a dormir
nós vamos conseguir aguentar uns bem
pessoal o que a equipe é que é mesmo o
pato donald ter os fogos pretos e um
deve estar morto
obviamente que está morto total ea
cabeça deu né é que o papel é que nunca
se chegou deve mexer nas noites mais pra
frente
está tudo tranqüilo e vou tentar falar a
voz
o cae e e e cinco da manhã vamos
conseguir ou não vamos conseguir ou não
não está quase está quase se está quase
lá
fica aí mickey
i wilson do sul que a história agora é
calma calma e quem não for sócio também
é em quem ninguém cada casa câmara calma
tá ok é conseguir eu acho é isso pessoal
nós vamos ficar porque com isto faz
night 73 já elano demo eu vou deixar um
em a descrição pessoal vocês podem
baixar e experimentar também e é isso
que o vosso feedback fiquem bem até a
próxima